SANDWICH, JAMES CORDEN.
I LIKE IT.
GOOD TO SEE YOU ALWAYS.
>>> WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN WITH
THIS -- GAS PRICES, HAVE YOU
HEARD, THEY ARE SPIKING, AND
MORE STATIONS ARE RUNNING DRY AS
WE ENTER DAY SIX OF A PIPELINE
SHUTDOWN DUE TO A HACK ATTACK.
SO YOU CAN SEE THE LONG LINES AT
GAS STATIONS ACROSS THE EAST
COAST.
GAS BUDDY SAYS ABOUT 1,800
STATIONS IN MULTIPLE STATES ARE
OUT OF FUEL, AND THE EXPERTS SAY
THE SHORTAGES ARE PRIMARILY
BECAUSE OF THE PANICKED BUYING.
AND PEOPLE ARE NOW HOARDING
GASOLINE.
>> IT COMES AFTER THE COLONIAL
PIPELINE WHICH SUPPLIES ABOUT
45% OF THE EAST COAST'S FUEL WAS
HIT BY A HACKER GROUP FROM
RUSSIA ON FRIDAY, FORCING THE
SHUTDOWN.
A LARGE PART OF THE SYSTEM IS
BACK ON LINE, AND MUCH OF THE
REST IS EXPECTED TO BE RESTARTED
BY THE END OF THE WEEK.
BUT IN THE MEANTIME, PANIC
BUYING AND SHORTAGES HAVE SENT
THE AVERAGE PRICE FOR A GALLON
OF REGULAR TO $3 ACCORDING TO
AAA.
IT'S BEEN NEARLY SEVEN YEARS
SINCE IT'S BEEN THIS HIGH.
>> JOINING US NOW IS HELIMA
CRAFT, A MEMBER OF THE NATIONAL
PETROLEUM COUNCIL AND THE GLOBAL
HEAD OF COMMOTY STRATEGY AT
THE INVESTMENT BANK RBC CAPITAL
MARKETS.
ALL THAT MEANS SHE KNOWS GAS
PRICES, WHY THEY GO UP, WHY THEY
DON'T.
GOOD MORNING TO YOU.
YOU KNOW, SEVEN YEARS AGO, THE
LAST TIME WE HAD GAS PRICES THIS
HIGH, IT WAS LARGELY BLAMED ON
TURMOIL IN THE MIDDLE EAST, IN
IRAQ IN PARTICULAR.
NOW WE HAVE THIS VERY DIFFERENT
CONFLICT ON OUR OWN SOIL.
HOW DID WE GET HERE, AND WHAT
NEEDS TO HAPPEN SO THAT DOES NOT
HAPPEN AGAIN?
>> I THINK THIS IS A STORY ABOUT
THE RISE IN CYBER ATTACKS.
I MEAN, IT'S THE PERFECT WEAPON,
A SHORT OF WAR WEAPON.
SO YOU HAVE A NUMBER OF STATE
ACTORS, NON-STATE ACTORS BEING
ABLE TO USE THIS TECHNOLOGY TO
WREAK HAVOC ON CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE ACROSS THE WORLD.
AND SO WE ARE TALKING ABOUT AN
ENERGY STORY THIS WEEK.
THE QUESTION IS WILL WE BE
TALKING ABOUT, YOU KNOW, THE
ELECTRICITY SUPPLY, WILL WE BE
TALKING ABOUT THE WATER SUPPLY.
SO I THINK, AGAIN, THE STORY
ABOUT ENERGY THIS WEEK, ABOUT
GAS LINES, BUT THE CYBER STORY
AND STORY OF CYBER ATTACKS IS
NOT GOING TO GO AWAY.
>> COLONIAL SAYS THEY SHOULD
HAVE THE PIPELINE BACK ON LINE
BY THE END OF THIS WEEK.
INHE MEANTIME -- YOU KNOW, THE
KEY WORD THERE IS SHOULD, THEY
SHOULD HAVE IT BACK ON LINE.
DO YOU EXPECT PRICES TO CONTINUE
TO GO UP?
>> I EXPECT PRICES TO CONTINUE
TO BE ELEVATED UNTIL WE GET AN
ANNOUNCEMENT FROM THE COMPANY
THAT THEY ARE FULLY BACK ON
LINE.
AND THEN THE SORT OF KINKS IN
THE DISTRIBUTION SYSTEM CAN BE
WORKED OUT.
NOW WE'RE NOT EXPECTING, THOUGH,
TO HAVE A SUMMER OF LOW GAS
PRICES BECAUSE WE'VE HAD THIS
RECOVERY FROM COVID.
PEOPLE ARE DRIVING AGAIN.
PEOPLE ARE GETTING ON PLANES
AGAIN.
BUT CERTAINLY THE SPIKE THAT
WE'VE SEEN THAT HAS BEEN DRIVEN
BY THIS, YOU KNOW, CYBERATTACK,
WE THINK THAT WILL BE MITIGATED
SOON.
>> IT'S ANTHONY.
WHY ARE WE SO VULNERABLE TO
THESE RANSOMWARE ATTACKS, AND IS
ANYTHING BEING DONE TO PROTECT
AGAINST THEM?
>> I MEAN, 85% OF CRITICAL
AMERICAN INFRASTRUCTURE IS IN
PRIVATE HANDS.
ONE OF THE ISSUES IS WITH
PRIVATE COMPANIES, THEY ARE NOT
REQUIRED TO DISCLOSE CYBER
ATTACKS.
THEY ONLY HAVE TO DO SO, FOR
EXAMPLE, IF SOCIAL SECURITY
NUMBERS ARE COMPROMISED.
SO THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS
REALLY TRYING TO WORK WITH THESE
COMPANIES TO PROVIDE MORE
INFORMATION ABOUT WHAT IS
ACTUALLY HAPPENING.
AND REALLY TRYING TO WORK WITH
THESE COMPANIES TO BOLSTER THEIR
CYBER DEFENSES.
THE RANSOMWARE ATTACKS ARE
COSTING SO MUCH MONEY.
LAST YEAR, THEY ROSE TO $20
BILLION IN COSTS.
THAT'S UP ALMOST $10 BILLION
FROM THE PREVIOUS YEAR.
>> SHOULD WE BE PAYING THE R
RA
RANSOMS?
>> COMPANIES ARE PAYING THE
RANSOMS.
WE DON'T KNOW HOW MANY COMPANIES
ARE PAYING THE RANSOMES, BUT
THEY ARE.
THE EMPHASIS NEED TO BE ON
BOLSTERING CYBER DEFENSES SO WE
ARE NOT IN THIS SITUATION, AND
BETTER INFORMATION SHARING.
>> EVEN IF THEY PASS THE COST TO
CONSUMERS, AT LEAST IT WOULD
IT'S INTERESTING THAT THE
HACKERS SEEM TO ACTUALLY WANT
THE MONEY, SUGGESTING THEY ARE
CRIMINALS AS OPPOSED TO PART OF
SOME KIND OF GOVERNMENT.
AND PRESIDENT BIDEN HAS SAID
THAT THERE IS NO EVIDENCE THAT
RUSSIA AS A GOVERNMENT IS BEHIND
THESE HACKS.
AND YET YOU'VE POINTED OUT THAT
THIS COULD LEAD TO AN ESCALATION
OF CYBER WARFARE BETWEEN OUR TWO
COUNTRIES.
HOW DO YOU SEE THAT GOING DOWN?
>> I MEAN, RUSSIA HAS BECOME A
SAFE HAVEN FOR THESE CRIMINAL
GROUPS ENGAGING IN RANSOMWARE
ATTACKS.
THE QUESTION IS, IS THERE TACIT
SUPPORT, DO THEY KNOW WHAT
THEY'RE DOING.
AND THEN YOU HAVE RUSSIAN
INTELLIGENCE SERVICES THEMSELVES
ORCHESTRATING ATTACKS.
WE HAD THIS MASSIVE SOLAR WIND
CYBER BREACH THAT WAS UNCOVERED
IN DECEMBER, 2020.
THAT WAS THE MOST MASSIVE CYBER
BREACH WE'VE SEEN IN HISTORY.
TARGETING CRITICAL FEDERAL
AGENCIES, TARGETING HOSPITALS,
DOING VACCINE RESEARCH ON
COVID-19.
AND SO THIS REAL CONCERN ABOUT
WHAT STATE ACTORS ARE DOING,
RUSSIA, CHINA, IRAN, IS ONLY
GROWING.
>> HELIMA CROFT -- GO AHEAD,
GAYLE.
>> I THINK THE SHIP HAS SAIL
GOOD TELLING PEOPLE DON'T DO
PANIC BUYING OF GAS.
BUT IS THAT ADDING TO THE
PROBLEM?
IS THERE A GAS SHORTAGE?
WHAT ARE YOU TELLING PEOPLE WHO
ARE SITTING IN THESE LONG LINES
WAITING AND DESPERATE?
>> I MEAN CERTAINLY WE HAVE NOT
HAD A SITUATION WHERE WE ARE
RUNNING OUT OF GAS BECAUSE WE
DON'T HAVE FUEL.
THERE IS AN ISSUE CLEARLY WITH
DISTRIBUTION, AND THERE IS AN
ISSUE WITH PANIC BUYING.
I THINK THE MOST IMPORTANT THING
FOR U.S. CONSUMERS IS TO SEE
CLEAR EVIDENCE THAT THAT
PIPELINE IS BACK UP AND RUNNING.
>>